something rare shocking happened on cnn
this week they told the truth
specifically chris cuomo admitted that
his network
are just a bunch of left-wing hacks who
cover republicans very differently
than democrats the news continues right
now on hand over chris for cuomo
primetime chris
state tv's got some new competition
anderson it's going to be very
interesting
uh to see how the narrative unfolds you
know for people like us
we do the job based on who's in power
but this is going to be very interesting
you notice what langford said there
how the media not this network
is playing his words which were he would
get
involved and now he isn't and we know
why he has no good reason
they do the job based on who is in power
that was a freudian slip where you say
one thing but mean your mother i think
he meant to say
regardless of who's in power but that's
not what came out and that's not what
would be true
he refers to fox news as state tv
meaning it supports the trump
administration
fox news was the first news outlet to
start calling this election
against donald trump for joe biden none
of what chris was saying is true other
than his admission that he covers people
differently but it's not just cnn
it's the entire establishment media
they themselves are the state tv they
themselves are the permanent state
and breaking up those norms is not
necessarily
the worst thing in the world i'm michael
knowles it's the michael knowles show
[Music]
that is the dirty little secret that for
the past
several generations the left has always
been in power
not just for four years or eight years
and then you win and then you lose no
the left has been in power regardless of
who wins elections for the past
several generations and one of the ways
they take power is pretending
that the right is in power chris cuomo
comes out and he says oh yeah state tv
you know is that's those are the
conservative outlets they support the
state the power you're the power chris
cnn is the power
donald trump has no power compared to
that liberal establishment
that's been trying to snuff him out
since day one my favorite comment
from yesterday from tasmanian devil
they're not attacking femininity
as much if or they are attacking
femininity rather
as much if not more as masculinity
it's so easy to be a woman just put on a
dress that's what the left
is saying you know candace owens i got
in a lot of trouble yesterday we covered
it on the show
because candace said that men shouldn't
wear dresses i know that's a very
controversial thing to say these days
but it's not just that the left is
attacking masculinity in that way you're
absolutely right
the left is also attacking femininity
when you attack sexual difference or
gender difference whatever term you want
you're not just attacking one of the
sexes
you're attacking both of them and you're
creating a caricature
you create a caricature of men which
you've the left has already been doing
for decades and decades
call it uh homer simpson syndrome or ray
romano syndrome the idea that
men are just doofuses idiots they can't
do anything you know they need to be
led around by the hand by their
brilliant flawless wives
so you attack the men but you're also
attacking the women because you're
saying if you put on a dress then you've
become a
slap on some lipstick and then you've
become a woman
it's a caricature that's why we said
yesterday the reason that drag
is funny or can be funny is because it's
it's so wrong it's so off we know that
it's in congress we know that someone
isn't
really a woman if he's a man who puts on
a dress the minute that you
start to take that seriously all of a
sudden it isn't funny
at all but the the left which is the
ruling established apparatus
they are the ones who are determining
these things they are the ones who are
setting
the standards and the norms and the left
accuses
the right of breaking norms they accuse
trump of breaking norms but those norms
those liberal norms we've had for
decade after decade after decade aren't
serving us very well
and and they are the ruling power i'll
give you an example
the daily beast this guy from the daily
beast msnbc
he just pointed out uh that
the suppression of the hunter biden
story on the new york post
was critical to joe biden's success
they think he won the election we'll see
if he actually won the election but if
he did
crucial to his success according to
biden campaign metrics
online chatter about the hunter biden
story during the elections last week
was greater than it was around hillary
clinton's emails during the last month
of 2016. but
what's the difference if that was so
much bigger then why did the media think
that biden won the election
quote it never spilled over into
mainstream outlets
he's bragging about this a journalist is
bragging about this that the media
who are supposed to report speak truth
to power
regardless of who's in power even though
chris cuomo admitted that's not what
they do
they ignored the story they suppressed
the story so that more people wouldn't
see it i think
if you ask people who are very online
like you and me if you ask people who
listen to a lot of political podcasts
read a lot of political writing then
sure they all knew about the
hunter biden story beyond that though
there are a lot of people who don't
spend a lot of time on twitter who don't
listen to a lot of political podcasts
they've probably never heard of it
and the biden campaign apparently
believes that that was a
huge issue is donald trump really in
power i mean i get you know
he has the presidency he had the
congress for a couple of years they
still have the senate
okay that's good that's something you
can get some judges through
but who's really ruling the country
the bureaucracy tech the media there was
a tech hearing
yesterday gets my blood boiling
the hollywood the mainstream media the
higher education system
lower education system all these
different systems totally dominated
by the left and so they can manipulate
whatever
you they manipulate the election the
biden campaign even isn't now apparently
admitting
that they manipulated the election to
their benefit
and then there's no consequence from it
sure they can pretend they paid lip
service to it
just yesterday jack dorsey goes to
capitol hill he's testifying on big tech
suppression
and he owns it he says i'm sorry i made
a mistake
absolutely my bad we shouldn't have
suppressed the story
thank you to the members of the
judiciary committee for the opportunity
to speak with the american people
about twitter and your concerns around
censorship and suppression
of a specific news article and generally
what we saw in the 2020 u.s elections
conversation we were called here today
because of an enforcement decision
we made against the new york post based
on a policy we created in 2018
to prevent twitter from being used to
spread hacked materials
this resulted in us blocking people from
sharing a new york post article
publicly or privately we made a quick
interpretation
using no other evidence that the
materials in the article were obtained
through hacking
and according to our policy we blocked
them from being spread
upon further consideration we admitted
this action was wrong
and corrected it within 24 hours we
informed the new york host of our air
and policy update and how to unlock
their account by deleting the original
violating tweet which freed them to
tweet the exact same content
and news article again they chose not to
instead insisting we reverse our
enforcement action
this sociopath
love i'm noticing these guys are really
they're letting their
guard down all these liberal elites on
their
blatant sociopathy recently
jack dorsey comes i'm really sorry yeah
that that thing we did where we
suppressed that really important news
story yes sorry out it swung the
election yeah hey
guys my bad my we good are we good
i know yeah you think i mean we're
saying now that joe biden won
and uh yeah we're probably responsible
for that because we threw the election
you know we shouldn't have done that
we won't do it again wink
what's where's the punishment where's
the consequence for his actions
and then he has the goal the unmitigated
goal
to blame the new york post he says look
you know that story that was blowing up
that everyone was trying to retweet you
couldn't do it you couldn't send it
anywhere
and then we took the new york post to
countdown the oldest continually
published daily newspaper
in the country founded by alexander
hamilton you know we took the account
down
and we admitted it was all wrong so we
just told them just delete the tweet i
know we said the tweet's not wrong but
just delete it just delete that tweet
and they didn't want to do it so it's
kind of their fault but yeah we're sorry
see you next time see in four years
can't wait to suppress all your stories
again
no consequences whatsoever that's an
apology and believe it or not
jack dorsey's apology was
was positively sincere compared to the
apology
of mussolini of gavin newsom in
california you know i have to tell you
you can tell
my set is different if you're watching
this show right now
i am out of california i am in
beautiful tennessee i am breathing the
sweet air of freedom
it's very very nice i miss my friends
and that's
it okay i i do not miss
california not at all i can rest easy
every night knowing that i am in a free
place the other reason i rest easy at
night is because i have my pillow
you know mike lindell mike lindell the
inventor of my pillow
a conservative leader in his own right
uh he's a
great businessman has a great
understanding of of the country
this guy makes great stuff okay my
pillow pillows won't go flat
i actually thought this before i tried
my pillow pillows i thought
look i like mike lindell i'm going to
use this product anyway just to kind of
support him he's
such a cool guy who knows if the
product's good or not so
i try it out it's the best pillow i ever
used the sheets are so soft they're
unbelievable
the pillows won't go flat by the way you
can wash and dry them as many times as
you want they maintain their shape best
of all they're made in the usa not
not too many places can say that these
days if you don't have a my pillow or
know someone
who doesn't now is the time because for
a limited time mike is offering his
premium my pillows
for his lowest price ever you get a
queen size premium my pillow that's
regularly 70 bucks
69.98 you can get it for only 29.98 that
is a 40
savings uh kings are only five dollars
more
i have the king it's great not only are
you getting the lowest price ever
but they are the best christmas gifts
ever go do it by now mike will extend
his 60 day money back guarantee
to march 1st 2021 go to mypillow.com
click the radio listener square
there you will find not only this
amazing offer but also deep discounts on
all the my pillow products the giza
dream sheets the my pillow mattress
topper and my pillow towel sets
or call 800-651-1148 and use promo code
daily wire you thought dorsey was bad
wait until you hear
gavin newsom's apology so you remember
gavin newsom we covered this on the show
maybe yesterday gavin newsom
broke his own mandates he broke his own
lockdown rules
he told everyone you can't go out you
can't go to restaurants wear the mask
all the time
he shows up to his buddy's birthday
party at french laundry which is an
extraordinarily expensive michelin rated
restaurant
something like 350 or 400 a plate
i looked if you want to add the ricotta
gnocchi the little a little dish of
ricotta in york it's like a 150
up charge okay it is uh
uh it's a nice restaurant and gavin
newsom didn't want to miss out on this
party so he goes and he thought the
cameras were off and he got caught
just like so many leftists have nancy
pelosi goes and gets her hair cut
all these other guys chris cuomo goes on
a run in the hamptons when he pretends
that he's
holding up in his basement and he's
going on a run he's going on a bike ride
he gets into a fight with a guy
they're all just lying to you all of
these people and then he gets caught
and he makes an apology that i was
listening very carefully
and for the first almost minute of it i
couldn't discern
any actual apology a few weeks ago i was
asked
to go to a friend's 50th birthday uh my
wife
and i friend that i've known for almost
20 years and
uh and a friend that had invite well put
a lot of
time and energy into his 50th birthday
it was in napa which was in the orange
status relatively loose compared to some
other counties
it was to be an outdoor uh restaurant
and we started the well the program
started at four o'clock it was one of
those early
reservations i got there a little bit
late at 4 30
and as soon as i sat down at the larger
table i realized it was a little larger
group
than i had anticipated and i made a bad
mistake
okay hold on there it is what was the
time what time did you have
i had 44 seconds of excuses
before he even started to intimate
that he had done anything wrong which by
the way he didn't ultimately say
he said i made a mistake but he didn't
make a mistake he chose to violate his
own orders
he chose to be a giant hypocrite he
chose to go to his buddy's birthday
party at the really nice restaurant so
it's not a mistake it's not an accident
like whoopsie daisy
oh no the french laundry fell down in
front of me i guess i'll eat the ricotta
gnocchi
whoops oh no oh my mouth is open and the
delicious regatta then yucky you're
falling in no
you chose to go and you then give 44
look my friend we've been friends for a
long time so that you know that makes it
okay
and look he put a lot of time and effort
into his birthday not like your idiot
friends i mean you're those you're lazy
stupid friends they wouldn't and by the
way your friends couldn't even afford
the french laundry so you don't really
it's just different you don't really get
it so i got they got there a little bit
late you know pretty busy on the
governor and everything
and i saw look there are a few more
people but it's like come on it's my
buddy's birthday and i want to do it and
i'm
i'm the ruler of california and i don't
have to play by the same rules that i
make everybody else follow
you know i made a mistake so then
he explains his mistake instead of
sitting down i should have stood
up and walked back got in my car and
drove back uh
to my house instead i chose to sit there
with my wife
and a number of other couples that were
outside the household
and you can quibble about the guidelines
etc etc but the spirit
of what i'm preaching all the time uh
was contradicted and i got to own that
and so i want to apologize to you
hold up stop it no you're not
apologizing at all
because even when you say i made a
mistake which is not true it wasn't a
mistake it was very intentional
you say look and we get there and i was
sitting there were some people and look
really i mean you could quibble about
the guidelines cause like
see actually i didn't i didn't really
violate them i think i mean but look we
can let's we can quibble
okay you you can have your view i can
have my view will agree to disagree no
you can't quibble buddy you broke the
rules
you had the rules that said you couldn't
go to that restaurant with all those
many people all together from different
households
you you made those rules and then you
broke them so i'm not going to quibble
about anything
you just want to hold your constituents
to a completely different standard
than you will hold yourself to because
you wanted those delicious gnocchi
at french laundry no quibbling
whatsoever
she says yeah i shouldn't look okay and
so i apologize good apologize please
give me the apology are we going to get
an apology
i need to preach and practice not just
preach and not practice and i've done my
best to do that
we're all human we all fall short
sometimes
we've been out i think for three times
since in fact i know
it's been three times because i remember
all of those dinners
very very vividly since february just
three times
twice with my wife by myself outdoors
and then this one occasion
with a larger group and there were just
a few extra people there
than the spirit of what i am promoting
oh it's not even an apology you're just
trying to get ahead of the story that's
inevitably going to come out that you've
broken your own guidelines
other times as well that's what this has
been because yeah and look okay i did it
i made a mistake i have
probably i've done it a couple other
times too um what was that governor
newsome no yeah no it's really i know
i'm going to keep smiling and it's all a
look it's kind of a big misunderstanding
but yeah for a while now i've been
disregarding the rules that i'm making
you all follow and
i know that maybe there's a chance some
journalist is going to cover this so
because the sacramento bee's really
angry at me so
yeah i've done it a few times but look
hey you know everyone makes mistakes
okay can we move on can we move past
this please
hahaha and i think i still am waiting
for the
real apology to come in and he just
closes his message to the people
smiling and so if we're gonna minimize
mixing you
you gotta own up to that so i just want
folks to know that
paid for our dinner uh and we uh you
know
we had an early dinner but didn't matter
i shouldn't have been there
i should have turned back around and uh
so when that happens
you gotta you pay the price but you also
own the mistake and you don't ever make
it again
and you have my word on that and you
have my word okay you gotta pay the
price i
obviously i don't i'm not gonna pay any
price and i'm not even really admitting
i did anything wrong it was an early
dinner you know it wasn't a late dinner
and i paid my way by the way
hey if any of you ethics researchers are
looking into this i paid for my dinner
even though they're
they're definitely lobbyists there but
anyway it's all of big misunderstanding
you gotta take ownership which i will
never ever do i'm
governor newsom goodbye does he look
sorry does he sound sorry to you
no not at all did chris cuomo sound
sorry no he didn't sound sorry at all
when he lied about quarantining with
coronavirus and he didn't actually
quarantine
he went outside and then he lied about
it then he filmed this whole ridiculous
charade
of him coming out of his basement for
the first time he wasn't coming out for
the first time
in weeks and seeing his family he had
been out and about on long island so
much so
that he got into a fight with a guy in
the street nancy pelosi did nancy pelosi
apologize
when she got caught going to that
hairdresser without a mask in violation
of the lockdown orders
no she actually blamed the hairdresser
do you remember that
i said oh this was a setup i shouldn't
have i can't believe she did that to me
no lady you broke your own rules what do
you mean her fault own up to your
mistake
dr fauci same thing even dr fatchi a
little less so it was a little less
publicized how many times did that guy
get caught without a mascot
after he told all of us that we have to
have our masks on after he told all of
us that none of us can have our masks on
none of these guys pay a price for any
of it
why because conservatives are not
ruling the country even when it's trump
even when
the republicans have both houses of
congress and the presidency
conservatives are not ruling this
country ever
the left rules this country you know
just just the social media example alone
i don't even want to talk too much about
this
social media issue because i feel
nothing comes of these
of these hearings but during this
hearing
the left democrats maisie hirono in
particular democratic senator from
hawaii
had the audacity to say social media
they're not
they're not biased against conservatives
actually
actually in in many ways they're biased
in favor
mr of conservatives the second time in
three weeks you've been
called before the senate committee so my
republican colleagues can
beat you up over claims that your
platforms are supposedly biased against
conservatives
the fact of the matter is that these
allegations are completely baseless
everyone who has systematically looked
at the content on social
media from media matters to the cato
institute to former republican senator
john kyle
has found absolutely no evidence of
anti-conservative bias
no evidence whatsoever of
anti-conservative bias and what's my
source
oh um media matters
far left radical activist organization
that is watching my show right now
that one there's a guy he's i i actually
i have great affection for this guy
he watches he's like the number one fan
of the show he watches
my show every single day my friend jason
campbell
and then whenever he can get like a good
clip and try to sort of
make it seem like i said something wrong
he will break it out they'll do and
they'll try to get conservatives fired
that's what the organization exists to
do it is a radical left organization
and maisie hirono is citing this
organization
as though they're unbiased fact checkers
that's what they all do
you know some are a little subtler about
it than media matters
you know media matters to their credit
at least they generally acknowledge that
they're very far left-wing
but but other fact-checking websites
that always
almost all the time seem to cut against
conservatives and
twist what conservatives are saying and
defend what liberals are saying
and bend over backwards to try to
rewrite what the liberals are saying to
defend it
politifact i'm thinking of snopes even
other organizations that fact check for
for
big tech those groups
will suppress a story those groups
according
reported later the biden campaign can
throw a presidential election
that's real power that's real power
and the truth doesn't really matter and
then they have the gall
to come to you and say that
conservatives don't care about the truth
barack obama was just talking about this
the other day you know i really it
drives me crazy to listen to him
slander conservatives in this way but if
i do have to listen
i at least want to listen on my raikons
you know because the raycons sound
really great
today you can save on a big wonderful
gift
that your friends will use every single
day raycon wireless earbuds with
seamless bluetooth pairing
and a comfortable noise isolating fit
you can start listening
right away and keep listening for hours
the audio quality is
phenomenal comparable to what you would
get from other premium brands except
raycon start at half the price you know
i
i've tried out the other ones and i
still do just to see
okay is it a raycon still uh you know
putting out a superior product here or
the other ones maybe the more
uh expensive ones that you're thinking
of are they the raycons are a superior
product there's just no question about
it this holiday season
get your friends and family something
that they can use for calls or for music
for work or for play at home or on the
go
pick up a pair for yourself you are
going to use them every day they are
really really excellent and you'll save
some money doing it go to byracon.com
knowles today to unlock exclusive deals
up to 20
off your raycon order hurry this offer
is available only for a limited time
and you do not want to miss it that is
by raycon dot com slash knoll skinner
wles
to unlock up to 20 off your ray cons by
raycon dot com
slash knowles barack obama
says that there is a truth decay
in this country that that republicans
and conservatives and trump in
particular
are overthrowing all these wonderful
norms
in our republic we have gone through a
presidency
that disregarded a whole host of
basic institutional norms
expectations we have for a president
that have been observed by republicans
and
democrats previously
uh and maybe most importantly uh and uh
most disconcertingly what we've seen is
what some people call truth decay
something that's been accelerated by
outgoing president trump the sense that
not only do we not have to tell the
truth
but the truth doesn't even matter pause
right there obviously the the hypocrisy
is is manifest uh talking about
overturning norms and things like that
talk about truth doesn't matter barack
obama actually one time when politifact
did
attack the left politifact pointed out
that the lie of the year was barack
obama who said if you like your doctor
you can keep your doctor and then
when he got caught in that lie he said
what you didn't think you were gonna get
all that insurance for free did you
totally cynical view is that the truth
didn't matter just like he says
when he said that if i pushed executive
amnesty
that would be unconstitutional and then
what's he do he pushes executive amnesty
shrugs his shoulders yep
truth doesn't really matter totally
cynical so obviously there's hypocrisy
there
and if we think of the norms being
constitutional government
barack obama broke a lot of those norms
didn't he he was
he was legislating with a pen and a
phone as they say he was
uh flagrantly violating the law he was
subverting the executive agencies for
his political purposes attacking his
political enemies through the irs and
the doj
okay spying on the trump campaign
however i actually want to defend what
barack obama is saying here i think he
actually is making a good point
it's a scary point but it's a good point
donald trump has overturned norms
not the constitutional norms those were
overturned long ago
donald trump is overturning the norms of
the liberal order the progressive
administrative state
which grows exponentially which
makes the laws without any
accountability to the people
which continues to move leftward without
any real resistance whatsoever
yeah but politicians in both parties
allowed this to happen democrats and
republicans
bushes and clintons and obama's allowed
this to happen
sure you can tinker around the edges of
policy but you better keep expanding
globalized trade
and you better keep outsourcing jobs and
you better keep the borders open
and you better keep flooding the country
with mass migration and you better keep
lowering wages
and you better keep moving to the left
and you better not put up any real
resistance against the
flood of social radicalism that has
redefined the fundamental political
institutions in the country
better not do any of that and if you are
going to even intimate that you'll do
that you better roll over and lose like
a good republican like mitt romney
you better not answer the media like
george w bush
yeah that's true there were there was
this norm there was this consensus
and it was a rotten norm and it was a
rotten consensus and it was terrible for
the country
and trump whatever flaws you think he
has
cracked that a little bit it's very good
to break up those norms
if you've got constitutional norms and
then progressive norms and those are at
odds
it's good to break up the progressive
norms
that's some truth but for barack obama
talks about the truth decay
barack obama's one of the most cynical
presidents in american history one of
the least concerned about the truth in
american history
but for him when he's even talking about
the truth what is he talking about he's
talking about a progressive view of
history
where we're hurtling toward utopia where
you're on the right side of history
that's his view of the truth not
objective truth
the way that you and i would talk about
it but ideological truth
truth within the system political
correctness political correctness which
is it
sounds similar to truth but it's not
it's actually opposed to truth
absolutely we need to break that
according to
those liberal norms conservatives lose
everything in culture
and politics great example of this great
example of the
rottenness of the liberal consensus just
came to us
has to do with love marriage and
divorce you know marriages do not stick
around forever necessarily one thing
though that will never completely lose
value would be a physical gold
it's a little bit of a rough segue but i
think the point is still valid physical
gold it's very important to have i love
investing
in that precious metals but here's
something new so you know that the price
of gold has been skyrocketing lately
they're there however is this problem
which is
gold is expensive probably we don't have
like lots of money lying around to start
buying gold bars left and right
this is where acre comes in this new
company acre
lets you subscribe to gold bars for as
little as 30
a month michael how can you do that gold
gold costs more than 30
a bar yeah it costs a lot more than that
however acres figured out this way
where you pay each month and then once
your gold stash reaches the price of
their gold bars
they will discreetly ship acre gold to
your house
acre lets you invest in physical gold
without coming out of pocket all at once
acre keeps you updated on your gold
stash every month
ships once you reach the price threshold
with acre
taking physical delivery of your gold
means that it is safe and sounded in
your hands acre just recently introduced
their new hundred dollar per month
subscription for their five gram
gold bar i've always enjoyed investing
in precious metals
go to get acre gold dot com slash nwles
start investing in physical gold today
make sure you go to this url because
acre by the way is giving away a free
gold bar that'd be nice to have
to qualify for the giveaway tweet or
post why you should be the recipient
and mention at get underscore acre
so the at sign get underscore acre
and tell them why you deserve a free
gold bar get acre gold dot com slash
knowles thank you aker gold for
supporting the show
we've got some very misleading headlines
i know you'll be shocked to hear that
from the mainstream media but it
actually shows you
the the problem the problem of framing
the problem of the real truth decay the
problem of our real
liberal rulers speaking of our liberal
rulers the youtube overlords
turns out are not huge fans of my
content
so be sure to ring the bell and
subscribe to the michael knowles show on
youtube
i've gotten messages from people who say
michael i did subscribe and then somehow
i got unsubscribed
yeah we've been hearing that a lot just
go even if you think you've subscribed
go check it out
we don't like these shenanigans the big
tech is already admitting they throw
presidential elections through their
shenanigans
then they say whoopsy daisy my mistake
no consequences at all so
check it out while we're still here we
have a ton of new content coming out
you will not want to miss it head on
over then go to dailywire.com we'll be
right back with a whole lot more
you want the good news or the bad news
you let's start with the good news
good news is the divorce rate in america
is it a 50-year low gosh isn't that
great
the divorce rate is at a 50-year low i
guess things are going pretty well i
mean we're i was worried about family
breakdown social breakdown
you know there were all those riots and
things in the streets it seems like a
lot of kids are growing up in these
broken homes and a lot of kids born out
of wedlock i mean i have looked at all
those statistics but
i'm being told that the divorce rate is
at a 50-year low that's great there were
even some kind of liberal conservatives
you know the squishy conservative types
who said oh this is so good
i'm so glad the divorce rate's low okay
that's what you want to know the bad
news
marriage rates are at an all-time low
they're they are as low as they have
ever been since we've been recording
those numbers
oh that's okay i'm glad the divorce
rate's low but it's like that
it's like that brilliant you know that
brilliant guy meme where you say well
if you you kind of tap your forehead you
say if you don't get married you can't
get divorced
i'm a very smart person there's the
trick no
i don't care if the divorce rate is at a
50-year low if no one's getting married
if
the marriage rate is lower somehow if
it's falling more precipitously
then that's that's bad news you got to
get married
there are a lot of these statistics that
we're told are evidence that the liberal
consensus you know the kind of obama
clinton bush just liberal neoliberalism
the kind of left liberalism right
liberalism you know it's all it's all
good
the unit party some people call it that
is so great you know and some examples
of this are people are living longer
which is somewhat true though actually
the life expectancy
declined in the united states uh during
the end of the obama administration kind
of moving into 2016 that time
it declined why because people were
killing themselves with well with guns
and other means of suicide and also with
drug overdoses
okay but generally okay people are
living a little bit longer it's
relatively peaceful i guess
i mean america's been at war for uh oh
yeah like my entire lifetime but i guess
it's relatively peaceful they're kind of
wars of empire over in the middle east
and in a lot of the wars you don't
really know why we're there libya why do
we go to libya why did obama start that
war in libya
that's another norm that trump broke
from my lifetime every president started
a war
except for trump trump pulled us out of
wars that's a no that's too bad
it's awful that he's breaking those
norms this liberal consensus that that
the
system sells to you all the time the
permissive state
doing whatever you want the the uh
administrative state the way that we are
governed the the
empire wars abroad we're the outsourcing
the mass migration
we are in the midst of a constant
propaganda flood
telling us why that's so great and
you've got to look past it because all
the headlines say
something to the effect of the
equivalent of the divorce rate has
fallen but what you got to look at and
realize oh a marriage has fallen as well
even as people let's say people have a
little bit more money fine but if
they're killing themselves at higher
rates if they're
overdosing on drugs at higher rates
something's gone rotten
the west has lost its soul you know i'm
reading this this book now by whitaker
chambers he was an ex-communist
and he became a christian this was one
of the books that changed ronald
reagan's life it's very
very important book in american
conservative politics and he points out
that it
it did make sense there is a reason that
the intellectuals were all communists
and especially
in the 30s and 40s why were they all
communists because they recognized that
something really was
rotten in modernity and they obviously
came to a much more rotten answer which
was communism but they were taking
seriously
these problems of history these social
problems that had come out of modernity
and we're still if communism obviously
was failed to use their terms it was
it's not now in the dust bin of history
but on the ash sheep of history
but the problems remain problems remain
according to these norms this was uh
this election was great you got to stay
home right there's no fraud there's no
fraud whatsoever that's great you're
mailing your ballot
we're getting evidence of voter fraud
every single day not just in
pennsylvania not just in georgia not
just in michigan
california even california and this is
some some voter fraud
where i saw something like this i don't
know if
this instance in particular was fraud
but the
mechanism by which these these
democratic operatives were working
clearly was
the same mechanism by which fraud could
be committed two individuals in
california have been charged with
multiple counts of voter fraud after
submitting fraudulent voter registration
applications
on behalf of homeless people this is
according to the l.a county
district attorney's office carlos
antonio de berbin montenegro what a name
and marcos raul aravallo were charged in
a 41 count criminal complaint filed last
week
these are not little kids by the way
these are not you know some 18 year old
activist hired by the democratic party
this is a 53 year old guy and a 34 year
old guy
these are older people more established
people and what they would do is they'd
go around to the homeless camps that
have
proliferated all around los angeles even
in the nice neighborhoods they're all
over the place shanty towns in full
parks
because of the failed governors and the
failed mayors there
and they would go and they would get all
these guys to register to vote
do you think these homeless guys
necessarily wanted to go register to
vote do you think they were looking
where can i exercise my right no i think
a lot of them were
extraordinarily strung out on drugs a
lot of them have a lot of mental
problems
a lot of them are they're living on the
street because they're
not capable of living on their own and
there's nothing compassionate therefore
about letting them live on the street
no one's trying to get them help these
left-wing operatives are not going out
there and saying hey come come into my
house
hey let's get you to a psychiatric
hospital hey no they're not doing any of
that they're saying hey
you i can exploit you for a vote that's
what we're going to do and they did that
montenegro what a name that guy uh
what's his full name carlos antonio de
bourbon montenegro it's like a
movie villain montenegro he submitted
over 8
000 fraudulent voter registration
applications between july and october of
this year 8
000. when we talk about the scale of
election fraud that's possible here
in the 2020 election people say oh it's
hard to invalidate ballots fraud doesn't
happen that much yeah we've never had
an election like this ever never had
widespread unsolicited mail-in ballots
like this but those are the norms
democrats go out they harvest ballots we
know that they do that we have motor
voter laws they're
people who are not eligible to vote
sneak in they vote anyway we know that
they stuff the ballot boxes i don't know
if they did in this election
maybe they did we know they have many
years past
those are the norms and then they win
and now with universal mailings they're
going to keep counting the votes until
they win
in just about every election now when
you break those liberal norms when you
go back to more of the constitutional
norms turns out we win
you can see this in house races from
2020.
according to the cook political report
listed 27 house races as
toss-ups 27 they didn't know which way
was going to go on election night
how many of those do you think
republicans won
what do you think 10 maybe i don't know
we're told it's blue waves they probably
should have won zero right no
how many they went 10 15 18 20.
27 that's how many they won all of them
the polling firms oh it's a toss-up it's
not a toss-up republicans won
all of them they went in and they fought
burgess owens you all know burgess owens
he just won a hotly contested race in
utah
he was trailing the incumbent by 11
percent in final polling
and the nonpartisan cook political
report
called it a toss-up and then he won
this system that we were told that's
constantly pumping propaganda
to to support itself is
separated from reality talk about truth
decay
okay it's we were talking yesterday
about alternate universes it is an
alternate universe
and that is the permanent state and when
it when
a state such as that when elites such as
that becomes
so self-serving you you saw it in in
newsom's apologies in jack dorsey's
apology when they're just
out helping themselves disappearing
rules people start to distrust the
system
actually regardless of your ideological
view left or right or partisan
you start to see that system cracking up
that is what's happening right now
that's not the people's fault that's the
fault of the people running the system
you don't even need to look in america
for this macron the leader of france
pointed this out he said that the left
in america
is burying american founding principles
that the norms have been the
constitutional arms have been broken the
left has broken them
macron said that the u.s mainstream
media
are legitimizing violence and that this
is a sign that the nation's founding
principles have been lost
and that is true of course that's true
the the left the media and the new york
times in particular
legitimize the violence the riots mostly
peaceful protests over the summer
legitimize the arson legitimize the
looting and they're defending islamist
terror attacks in france
they're saying well we need to
understand it why is this happening why
they're not
they're not defending the founding
principles because they're not governed
under those founding principles
progressives have told us for 100 years
they think the founding principles are
bunk they think the founding system of
government is bunk
they want a new one and they're going to
create it
they're kicking great american books out
of schools
i kid you not we were talking yesterday
about the book burning at target that
that you have uc berkeley professors
english professors
saying that we need to actually burn
books that suggest that we shouldn't
castrate children
and trans the kids well now a california
school district in l.a county
is removing huckleberry finn
to kill a mockingbird and of mice and
men
from their curriculum why they're
removing it because they say it's
racist or something they say it's
oppressive they say it's part of an
oppressive past
these are some of the greatest works of
american literature
certainly the most important works of
american literature for young adults to
read
being removed from the curriculum we've
been predicting this for years the left
told us oh you're crazy you're
hysterical
it's happening why is it happening in
part it's happening because the left
because the right rather refuses to
articulate a standard
when when we hear the media talking
about the erosion of norms and standards
when we hear about political correctness
which poses a new standard
the right gets backed into a corner
where we say hey i'm against censorship
i'm for free speech we use
bumper stickers and slogans but we fail
to articulate a standard ourselves
we want to be inclusive so we say oh you
can add your books to the curriculum you
can wear whatever you want to wear
the men can wear dresses whatever
but we just want to have our books too
the problem with this is
it's not doesn't persuade anybody and in
the case of education
education is by definition coercive
and exclusive there's only so many weeks
in the semester there's only
only so many books you can read and if
you start adding in some crazy gender
theory book or some crazy
ibram kendi book about it you know how
awful white people are and we're a white
supremacist country or whatever
you have to remove a book and
the process you're seeing playing out in
these schools is okay we're going to
remove huck finn we're going to remove
to kill a mockingbird we're going to
remove
of mice and men it has nothing to do
with the intrinsic quality of these
books
all of which are much better than
anything ibram kindy has ever thought or
said in his entire life
but it's because those books uphold a
certain standard in a certain culture
and they come in a certain western
tradition and the left wants to get rid
of that we need to offer a standard we
need to say no you can't add your stupid
book
your your your book of lower quality
cannot come into the curriculum because
it will make our kids dumber
and we need to have good books in the
curriculum and we should only teach good
books
and not bad books because there's only
so much time and i want my kids to be
smart and i want your kids to be smart
and so we got to read the good books
that make you smart
getting back to that point yesterday at
candice's point about men wearing
dresses hairy styles
we need to be able to say no men
shouldn't wear dresses when men do wear
dresses you know
people kept posting this image of rudy
giuliani he went on saturday night live
one time and he wore drag
and donald trump was actually in the
sketch they say what you didn't attack
rudy giuliani
rudy giuliani was putting on a comedic
performance
rudy giuliani was not saying it is
perfectly normal for a man to wear a
dress
he was saying the opposite he was saying
it's completely absurd for a man to wear
a dress
that's why it's a comedic performance
that's why
drag is funny it's funny because it's
wrong
some people wrote in yesterday that
michael drags not funny at all it's
wrong it's an abomination
sure i guess right but that's the point
that's why it's funny
there is there is such a thing as dark
humor there is such a thing
incongruity is necessarily wrong right
but it's that's why it's funny it's
because it doesn't balance it doesn't
make sense it isn't
quite right conservatives need to be
able to say no hey men don't wear
dresses
but come on it doesn't bother you it
doesn't affect your culture yes it does
don't wear dresses conservatives frankly
need to be able to say don't wear the
mask
only in narrow narrow narrow
circumstances should you wear the mask
or
maybe not even then now but you could
say well michael no
look i'm a conservative i just want
people to if you want to wear the mask
you can and if you want to wear a dress
you can and if you want to
take to kill a mockingbird off your of
your curriculum you can and it's all we
can all just do whatever we want no we
can't
people ask me this all the time since
i've been on this hobby horse about the
virus since the beginning
you say ah you know michael why do the
masks
have to be political or they'll say
about the dresses with candace why
why does a man wearing a dress he's an
actor or something he's a
singer he's wearing a dress who cares
why does that have to be political
the reason it has to be political is
because masks
public masking everybody in america just
wearing masks like banditos across their
face
that is a public matter and public
matters are by definition
political that's just what political
means it just means public what we all
do in public together
men wearing dresses why does that have
to be political because it's happening
in public
and that is therefore political and it
affects the culture it affects the way
we view ourselves
it affects the norms of society every
society is going to have some norms
and the left has clobbered the norms
they've transformed the norms and
conservatives don't have the spine
to go out and say no actually we should
i think we should have other standards
i think we should we should i think we
should have we should have a curriculum
in schools but it should have good books
not bad books i do think men should wear
clothing but they should wear good
clothing not bad clothing
appropriate clothing not inappropriate
clothing we should use language we
should use
good respectful serious concise precise
language
not euphemistic dishonest language like
political correctness
we should have media platforms but they
should tell the truth they shouldn't
tell lies
we should have technology platforms that
allow you to communicate don't suppress
communication
have a standard before we go i have to
get to this one book we were talking
about books i can't
i read the book review of barack obama's
new memoir
this is called a promised land
barack obama a promised land this is his
third memoir
his third book about his favorite
subject
he wrote his first memoir i think in his
20s
he wrote his next memoir what in his 30s
now he's got a third memoir
third book about his favorite subject
here's the book review in the new york
times
a promised land by barack obama barack
obama is as fine a writer as they come
if i were tw twitter right now i would
say this this claim is disputed
fact check warning do not barack obama's
as fine a writer as they come
no his first book actually was was
fairly well written
but who knows did he write that book who
knows uh
there are always rumors did he hire a
ghost writer did i don't know maybe he
wrote the book okay
even if he did write that book there are
finer writers
it is not merely that this book avoids
being ponderous as might be expected
even forgiven of a hefty memoir but that
it is nearly always
pleasurable to read sentence by sentence
the prose gorgeous in places the detail
granular and vivid
the book is like 750 pages
and i imagine the one true thing in this
sentence is the book is probably not as
ponderous as this pretentious and
ridiculous review
from southeast asia to a forgotten
school in south carolina he evokes the
sense of place with a light
but sure hand this is the first of two
volumes
okay well that's gonna be a long one
starts early in his life
charting his initial political campaigns
blah blah blah
his focus is more political than
personal but when he does write about
his family
it is with a beauty close to nostalgia
okay i can't i can't even read anymore
this is a new york times review by
chimamanda ngozi adichie
who is the author of we should all be
feminists and a feminist manifesto and
15 suggestions
ah i mean something i haven't read the
book yet so i don't want to judge it
something tells me it's not one of the
great books
but this is this is the standard right
this is the standard that
the the media are going to judge by this
is what we are told is good
all cultures have some sense of the good
they have something to that they are
aiming toward they have things that they
exalt
they have things they hold sacred you
know we are
we were told the other day that america
worships whiteness by that crazy senate
senate candidate in georgia and that of
course is not true
actually we only have one taboo word in
america and the taboo word is not
cracker or honky right it's the end it's
not the c word or the h word
it's the n word we actually take these
racial matters very seriously in america
and we have a sort of sacred taboo
in in favor of you know being
kind and welcoming and inclusive toward
historically oppressed groups and racial
minorities
okay there there is a cultural
taboo what are we pointing toward is
good what we're pointing toward is good
here
is liberalism progressivism
leftism those are the books we have to
read you got to kick out the traditional
books
we're told it's good to dress in a way
that is progressive and transgressive
not traditional and conservative if
conservatives
do not grow a spine and articulate
their own standards we are going to
continue down this path and we will have
norms and we will have normalcy
and the left might even stop rioting if
they get their way in elections however
they get their way
and the media will start being nice
because they change their coverage based
on who they're covering
and we will continue to have this
permanent state
this uniparty that allows our country to
degrade and degrade and degrade and
decay until we've lost it completely
so we have to keep fighting i'm michael
knowles this is the michael also i'll
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boring our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
assistant director pavel wadowski editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva and
production assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20.
you know the matt wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about
i hope you'll give it a listen